le trempage, c'est quand euh
vous avez un homme
qui
le colle et le laisse essentiellement
tremper nous avons été élevés comme des
mormons orthodoxes mariés en 1921 en tant que vierges
[Musique]
je suis spartacus et vous regardez
x mormon tick tock et l'idée derrière
ça  est-ce que si c'est juste dedans mais pas d'avant
en arrière ou s'il n'y a pas
de mouvement,
ce n'est pas un péché,
nous ne savions rien à faire,
je me suis fait larguer par un gars qui m'a dit que
sa bénédiction patriarcale disait qu'il
épouserait une fille qui
skie et  j'étais un snowboardeur on m'a donné
deux autres joyaux de conseils ne jamais dire non à
votre mari et seules les femmes [ __ ] et mondaines
l'aiment vraiment
donc
chaque personne qui a atteint un certain
niveau de l'église mormone,
nous utilisons le mot doté ou a atteint
un certain  le niveau de dignité doit porter
le vêtement mormon qui est le
terme officiel pour les sous-vêtements magiques mormons la seule
fois où j'ai enlevé mes vêtements était pour prendre une
douche pour nager
pour avoir des relations sexuelles et occasionnellement pour faire de l'exercice
ouais donc
je me suis marié dans ce les vêtements sont
censés une protection  de satan j'ai
aussi dû chanter en cercle
ouais couvrant mon visage oh ouais n'oubliez pas
[Musique]
en tant que mormons vous vous
concentrez fortement sur le livre de mormon
parce que nous croyons que c'est le
livre traduit le plus corrigé
qu'il y ait
[Musique  ]
l'église utilise beaucoup de contrôle de la pensée
et de manipulation mentale et émotionnelle
dans tous ses
enseignements, un exemple de cela serait
l'enseignement insidieux des familles peut
être ensemble pour toujours
à la surface cela semble être un très
bel enseignement sur les familles éternelles
jusqu'à ce que vous réalisiez  que c'est en fait
très conditionnel sur la base de
tout faire exactement comme l'
église mormone veut que vous le fassiez
[Musique]
donc il y a une chose dans l'église mormone
qui s'appelle trek où tous
les adolescents mormons se déguisent en
pionniers
et tirent la main  chariots euh pour se souvenir des
ancêtres qui ont voyagé dans l'utah donc l'utah
a été fondé par les mormons la majorité
des gens qui vivent dans l'utah sont des mormons
comme certains d'entre vous savent peut-être que la maison de la ruche
est l'endroit où brigham young a logé toutes
ses nombreuses épouses
55 pour être exact
les gens quittent l'église mormone en
masse à cause de problèmes liés à l'histoire de l'église
tels que les anachronismes dans le livre
de mormon joseph smith étant un
prédateur sexuel la polygamie et bien d'autres j'ai
réalisé beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
dans des doctrines que je ne connaissais pas  à peu près
comme dans les années 1900 qui étaient si
racistes si mal si sexistes, j'ai
dévalé un terrier de pléthore d'
informations où la littéralité de ce qu'on
m'a enseigné sur l'église
ne
concordait pas, alors j'ai traversé un très long
et douloureux processus de déconstruction  ma
foi
[musique]
en grandissant dans l'église mormone, on m'a
appris
que ce
café n'était pas mauvais, donc beaucoup
de mes choix de vie ont été faits pour moi
parce que je faisais partie de l'église lds,
j'ai l'impression qu'une grande partie de ma vie était
littéralement volé de moi je suppose que je suis un
pécheur qui boit du jus de satan
mais
liz c'est vraiment bien il y
a tellement de deuil qui vient de
quitter l'église mormone tu
perds ta communauté tu perds beaucoup
de tes amitiés je suis tellement
reconnaissant pour  la communauté que j'ai trouvée
ici sur tic tac qui
comprend juste ce que je traverse